CPAC finally started and it's really
humiliating and embarrassing here is the
start of it with Matt schlapp who runs
the event remember much of the
controversy around CPAC this year is
that match lap who is anti-gay
and married to a woman he is accused of
having I I can't even do it he's accused
of having pummeled the junk of another
man uh sexual assault we're talking
about many people didn't want to go to
CPAC here is Matt schlapp uh addressing
Jim Jordan as maybe the most powerful
man in Washington there's a lot of
chatter in the media about
about here and not here I'm really proud
to be standing alongside someone I think
might just be the most powerful man in
Washington DC
you know I don't think that Jim Jordan
is at this point the most powerful man
in Washington D.C but it's the perfect
person for schlap to point to because
Jordan has quite a history of looking
the other way when bad things are being
done let's just leave it at that
um Kurt schlichter was there and he had
quite an interesting anecdote these are
the sorts of colorful stories we've come
to expect at CPAC clicker my friend from
town hall who has a very important
historic distinction he was kicked off
and banned from the Don Lemon show
I forget what did you say again well so
I'm on I'm on the show and he he says
this is when we run up to Trump and he
says you know Kirk this is terrible this
is the worst thing ever do you know what
what Donald Trump said and I'm like I
don't know and he says
he said
that Hillary got schlonged when she was
running against uh
that was a good one and I I got I said I
don't care Hillary Clinton I mean you
care about that Hillary Clinton
literally stood by while her husband
used an intern as a humidor whoa that is
totally normal
you can't say that so I said she sat
there and literally stood by as her
husband used
an intern is a human door and boot off
of CNN best thing ever happened to me so
that's all right a true tale of
redemption and forgiveness or something
like that uh they're still doing the
election with stolen stuff here is
Stephen Bannon interviewing Kimberly
Guilfoyle and someone else looks like
Miss Miss Indiana maybe or something I
can't tell and uh playing up the entire
Biden's not the legitimate president
stuff you said the bidens were the
occupiers of 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue
are you implying they did not win the
2020 election ma'am I'm straight out
saying that they did not that's why
you're an occupier it's like it's like
the equivalent of a squatter right do
you agree with that do you think Joe is
Joe Biden the legitimate president
United States
no definitely not all right and then a
woman traveled all the way to CPAC I
guess because she loves Steve Bannon and
Steve Bannon suggests not watching Fox
News anymore which is interesting
Rooney and I actually came here because
I love Donald Trump and I love Steve
Bannon also in real America voice and
I'm I'm with a little group in Pueblo
Colorado who are grandparents for
America and would you say gun parents or
grandparents planting trees under which
we will never sit because we're trying
to get Paul
personality we can't win the personality
War right it's the left that's voting
for personality that oh my goodness that
is genius huh we can win the policy War
they're all in our favor so we did a
brochure that puts Republicans I'm
curious are there any policies that the
country is moving in their favor I can't
think of a single one policies on one
side Democrat policies on the other if
you pick all the Democrat policies vote
that way we just want you not to be
stupid right all right you don't know
what you're voting for
ma'am if you don't want to be stupid
stop watching Fox
es
[Applause]
there were some except for us there did
you hear that he's like except for did
he say except for Maria Bartiromo and
someone else
so this is another unhinged year of CPAC
we will be live later today and then
tomorrow with the Trump speech and it is
it is a Gong Show it really is but
hopefully I don't have to suffer through
it alone and some of you will join me
make sure you're subscribed on the
YouTube channel youtube.com slash the
David packman show one of our sponsors
today is Magic spoon the breakfast
cereal with the crunchy sweet goodness
you love but with high quality
ingredients less sugar and more protein
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar it's
packed with 13 to 14 grams of protein
and just four to five net carbs so it's
great if you're doing keto or low carb
or if just like me you're trying to
limit your sugar intake they have many
unique flavors so you'll never get bored
my personal favorite is maple waffle but
I grew up in New England so maybe that's
why Maple you know they also have cocoa
fruity frosted peanut butter blueberry
muffin honey nut cookies and cream
cinnamon roll sometimes there's really
just no substitute
for sitting down with a nice bowl of
cereal who doesn't love that when the
mood strikes go for something more
wholesome with plenty of protein and
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked simply go to
magicspoon.com Pacman you can create a
custom bundle and use the code Pacman
for five dollars off the link is down
below